today we are unboxing the first 5g pc
[Music]
this is the lenovo flex 5g a huge thank
you to qualcomm for sponsoring this
video and sending this over for me to
check out and show to you guys one of
the things that i'm most excited about
with this is obviously 5g because it's
incredibly fast but the battery life on
this thing is incredible they said that
i can get up to 24 hours of video
playback and multiple days of use on
this thing on one charge
oh i just cut all the way through the
cardboard
we've got another box
charger cable which we're hardly going
to need because the battery life is so
good which is great because do i ever
want to get off my couch now
[Music]
so this weighs 1.3 kilograms and i'm
gonna have to convert that into pounds
right here for myself
oh this is so thin we have two usbc
ports over here we also have an airplane
mode
headphone jack and the power button this
is also powered by usbc
as well which is great honestly all i've
ever wanted is just a laptop that is
constantly connected i used to go to a
lot of coffee shops to work and i would
never feel
secure connecting onto their wi-fi
networks but now with 5g i could be
running the world let's see what else is
in the box and then we're going to set
it up oh we have a sim card ejector
because you know why this is always
connected
i just wanted to make sure there was
nothing that
just wasn't missing anything because we
know i've done that before and then i'm
digging through the trash to look for
something you guys in the comments are
like justine you just threw away insert
important thing here
step one unbox step two plug in step
three plug into wall step four turn on
here is where our sim card is already
there verizon 5g okay now i got to put
it back in
[Music]
here we go let's start up time
to set it up i'll be with you guys in
just a moment
the lenovo flex 5g is powered by a 2.84
gigahertz qualcomm snapdragon 8cx 5g
compute platform it's thermally
efficient and really quiet since it
doesn't have any need for fans to cool
it it uses 60 less power and has twice
the performance than the previous
generation so that'll give you multi-day
battery life the 14 inch full hd
wide-angle touch screen display gives
you enough space for work conference
calls or just watching content it
seamlessly switches between 4g lte 5g
and trusted wifi networks so you'll stay
securely connected to the best available
networks the flex 5g enables super fast
download speeds of up to 4 gigabits per
second which is 10 times faster than a
4g data connection this was designed to
go head-to-head with competing
processors but at a fraction of the
power consumption all of this making for
a very versatile two-in-one
[Music]
so i wanted to test out doing a video
call and i was gonna go visit jenna but
she actually doesn't know that i'm gonna
go visit her yet
she just got some birthday candy from my
parents and i don't have any candy at my
house i'm gonna do a quick little call
to kind of see what it would be like if
i had to do a business call i mean i
think this is business candy is business
this is very serious business
[Music]
hi
how's it going good i was sweeping my
porch oh that sounds like fun
no i just remembered that you had candy
and i wanted some candy and i don't have
any candy at my house i have a lot of
candy you also have really fast 5g by
you which is exciting i do i actually do
well i wanted to show you my new lenovo
flex 5g it's pretty cool it's like one
of the first five gpcs it's pretty
awesome
why are you here already well because i
was filming a video with it and then i
thought candy yeah come on over i'll see
you no okay bring the dog i'll bring
maddie and we can watch some some
content on it i'll show you how cool it
is okay bye bye
do you want to go see her we're going to
go see her okay how about that that'd be
fun oh big stretch is it a big stretch
if you don't say big stretch one thing i
do really love about it is how light it
is i mean this is so extremely light
let's go
do you like
that we can be in the car
and be on our laptop and have service
wherever we are 5g 95g
[Music]
there's an airplane button well yeah
because it's
5g enabled so it's basically
always connected i'm really excited
that's what i skyped you on it looked
really good okay let's walk maddie and
we can go have some snacks candy i'm
here for the candy
[Music]
so i'm back after spending a few days
with this two in one and what i've liked
the most like i said before is the fact
that it is always connected so wherever
you have cell reception you'll be able
to be connected to the internet now 5g
is interesting because 5g is not
everywhere yet so i went and took a look
at the coverage map and i found a
location that was near my sister so i
went to visit her because she has a
tower next to her another thing that i
like is we went to a coffee shop and the
coffee shop had a sign that said
no laptops well here's the thing i can
technically say well it's not really a
laptop it's a two-in-one
oh i won't use my laptop here i'll just
use my tablet i think what makes me so
excited about this device in general is
obviously this is one of the first 5g
enabled pcs all of our devices will
eventually be connected when 5g is so
readily available that you just walk
outside and it is everywhere it's going
to be so
shocking the amount of things that we're
going to be able to do with those speeds
we'll be able to edit in the cloud we'll
be gaming in the cloud everything will
basically be taking place not on your
device but somewhere else
on the internet qualcomm really is
pushing the limits of what you can do
with these types of devices and i'm
extremely excited to see what they do in
the future so with that my friends i'm
going to take my
not a laptop back to the coffee shop
thanks again to qualcomm for sponsoring
this video i'll see you guys in the next
one
you